today is really going to be about an
hour special announcement regarding how
we continue to strengthen and change
education K through 12 education how we
provide the outcomes and access and
opportunity that our kids deserve and
when we give our kids these
opportunities they thrive and they
flourish and they do things that amaze
us today's about providing economic
opportunities for people who need it
most and for people that will give them
that opportunity they do the most and I
couldn't be more proud to be here today
today we're proving that when we work
together special things happen and we
forget about what territory we sit in
what group we represent who we are
individually and rather we come together
real things start to happen so without
any further ado governor well be sorry
and glad you're here
talk about stepping up the Dahlia
Foundation has stepped up in a
significant significant way you know
it's a partnership we have together the
Dahlia foundation is going to contribute
100 million dollars to make sure your
education is the best that it can be
your education is the best that it could
be we educate the whole person we love
the student and we as a state are gonna
do our part we're gonna match that over
a period of five years and Ray and
Barbara and I are going out we're also
finding others of philanthropic
folks who have a big heart who are gonna
step up and match that as well this is
300 million dollars invested in you
invested in our urban high schools
invested in rural high schools making
sure that each every kid gets their best
shot and I could not be more proud ray
and Barbara I could not be more proud to
be doing this with you
so that's a tough one to follow up I'm
introducing somebody who our students
know very very well and I couldn't be
more thrilled to talk about someone who
who really gets it who really gets what
happens when we invest in children who
really gets what happens when we honor
families and put them forward first for
us here in East Hartford we know barber
Dalio because we participate in the
summer Leadership Institute we know a
barber Dalio because she's giving us
opportunities to attend summer wishbone
experiences it has taken us all over the
country and open up our eyes the
opportunities that you know for me maybe
I just never had a shot at seeing and
Barbara I couldn't be more appreciative
to be your friend and to have you here
as a partner and I'm just so thrilled
you're here today and and on behalf of
all of our kids and families really want
to express our gratitude thank you
they thank you for having us I know that
this is a big production to bring all
the faculty and and so many students I
really appreciate that thank you
Thank You governor for partnering with
us and thank you everybody for coming
together
I love public education I'm always
humbled and inspired by everything you
do you're amazing I started working with
public education about 10 years ago and
I came across over the years with some
students that had dropped out of school
and other students that were not to
engage not because they didn't want to
but because of the poverty and their
difficult circumstance it made it made
it hard so they got in a cycle that is
difficult to break and by giving them
job opportunities like technical skill
career training we can break that cycle
so we commissioned a report and it
showed that there are 39 thousand of
those students that are disengaged or
disconnected I know that there are not
too many answers but I know that if we
come together we'll find the answers
we're very excited about this
opportunity we're excited and hopeful
and really look forward to getting
together and start brainstorming about
all the amazing possibilities thank you
so much
I'd like to tell you a little bit about
where we're coming from I grew up in a
high school which was very much like
this and I was lucky to be in a
lower-middle-class family who with
parents who cared for me and teachers
who cared for me and then I was very
lucky 41 years ago to marry Barbara
I mean basically basically all you
really need right all you really need is
is a good public school education with
people who care about you and then marry
a good lifer
right that's all you need so just to cut
short about this 10 years ago Barbara
was drawn into the communities and and
learned and she was affected by all of
you really she was affected by you
inspired by you so for the last 10 years
at the dinner table all I was hearing
about was you and how you inspired and
also the lack of opportunities in other
words just the not enough resources so I
was very lucky in my life to be able to
live the American dream right and what
it means most fundamentally is equal
opportunity and most fundamentally equal
opportunity and education most
fundamentally there's no good reason
there shouldn't be equal opportunity
that's education when you think like
what is the best investment you could
make it has to be in the children's
education right that's a destiny and the
teachers
[Applause]
it's it's fundamental and and then
there's community there a number of
professors who've studied what happiness
is is due to and they they find that
there's nothing that passed a basic
level of income there's no correlation
between the amount of money that you
have in the happiness that you have the
number one influence in the in happiness
is a sense of community do you have a
good community and so when we think
about Connecticut we think about can
this is our community right we're in
this thing together so we each can bring
different things we can bring some
resources and then when we see the
talents and the programs we there's so
many potential things that can be
achieved so our number one objective is
to get particularly those who are having
the most truck trouble to get them
through high school and into jobs like
education can't be theoretical it's got
to deliver an outcome and if you don't
have an outcome in sight when you're
going through high school that tangible
outcome you not gonna have the pull to
get through it and so we want so that's
what we're in a mission and it was so
great that when we would discuss this
with the governor like we came up you
know let's do it let's do this thing
that we can do this thing so
[Applause]
so we you know and it's pulling together
right I mean they're not only well we
really believe that we're going to have
a great return on investment because
we're going to have the double bottom
line of a great social investment and
then also when you think about the
economic implications of getting kids to
graduate school and get into a job and
what that creates for them and what it
creates for the community it's a highly
economically and spiritually exciting
thing to do so you know where that's why
we're really excited to do that and when
we hear programs and see programs and
and Barbara's very modest as you could
tell and the the impact that she's been
having if you want to check out where
we're coming from ask around because
there's ten years of Barbara leaving her
fingerprints all over the place so we
can do this now in scale because
there'll be resources so anyway we're
really excited to do this so thank you
for your partnership
[Applause]